j'ai une enfance de juifs religieux de
juif orthodoxe qui allait à la synagogue
quasiment tous les matins qui prit trois
fois par jour qui avait une kippa sur la
tête dehors dedans partout qui avait des
petites titres qui étudiaient le Talmud
la Bible continuellement et surtout je
voulais être à bain et je voulais
vraiment l'être je me préparais à l'être
je donnais même des cours de religion
dans dans de commentaires biblique dans
ma dans ma synagogue et j'étais très
heureux dans cette perspective et en
fait à la fin de mon lycée juste avant
de commencer mais enfin mes études
rabbiniques j'ai entre guillemets je le
dis en une phrase mais j'ai perdu la foi
enfin tous ces tous ces écroulé
précisément par la découverte de la
philosophie et donc j'ai vraiment rompu
totalement avec la religion pas avec le
judaïsme mais avec la religion et je
suis totalement ça veut dire j'ai tourné
le dos à ma pratique j'ai perdu mes amis
enfin j'ai vraiment j'ai fait une sorte
de nouvelle vie de nouvelles naissances
et je me suis lancé dans dans les études
philosophiques dans la littérature dans
l'écriture et donc précisément ce que
j'ai appelé penser contre moi-même au
sens extrêmement littéral et au sens
extrêmement incarné si je vous écoute
finalement penser contre soi-même c'est
une éthique de vie oui c'est une éthique
de vie exactement et cette éthique de
vie c'est aussi que penser contre
soi-même ça suppose je pense très
minimalement de pas être dogmatique de
peine dogmatique en philosophie et de
palettes dans sa vie d'être à l'écoute
des autres de pas de pas de pas
s'opposer de pas s'opposer de manière
stérile et ferme à des discours
d'écouter ses discours là d'écouter
leurs argumentations d'accepter parfois
d'être fragilisé par les discours des
autres d'être heurté penser contre
soi-même je dirais que c'est la
définition même de la philosophie et
c'est un idéal qui est impossible à
accomplir pleinement et à mon avis il
faut l'assumer comme tel ce qui signifie
d'ailleurs c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
la philosophie que que personne ne peut
réussir à philosopher vraiment moi je
n'ai pas choisi de naître le 8 décembre
97 j'aurais pu naître 100 ans avant 100
ans après ou bien plus tard je n'ai pas
choisi de naître en France je n'ai pas
choisi de naître dans tel ou telle
famille etc et donc évidemment ma
naissance c'est ce qu'on appelle en
philosophie être jeté je suis jeté dans
le monde et jeter dans un point du monde
et le point par lequel je découvre le
monde est évidemment un point qui va
véhiculer en moi un certain nombre de
préjugés de présupposés de valeurs de
grandes idées que je n'ai absolument pas
choisi qui sont relatives et qui
auraient pu être tout à fait différente
si j'étais né en Inde il y a 800 ans et
donc à partir de là la tâche de la
philosophie la philosophie au sens entre
guillemets professionnelle lutter mais
même au sens où tout le monde peut
philosopher et je pense que la
philosophie est une démarche universelle
la tâche de la philosophie c'est
d'essayer de faire en sorte que sa
pensée ne soit pas simplement
l'épiphénomène de sa propre naissance de
sa propre incarnation et dans son et de
son propre soi-même donc c'est une
expérience d'altérité ça suppose de
s'intéresser aux pensées des autres de
s'intéresser avec curiosité de
s'intéresser me semble-t-il aussi avec
scepticisme avec une forme de doute
pensez qu'on reçoit même c'est un
travail de tous les jours c'est une
tâche quotidienne ça suppose de ne
jamais vouloir bloquer figer sa pensée
de ne jamais la transformer en dogme de
ne jamais jamais la transformer en
doctrine de ne jamais la transformer en
religion mais d'essayer toujours de
faire en sorte que la pensée soit dans
un rapport de négation de soi à soi et
donc cette tâche là qui a une tâche à la
fois extrêmement dur et en fait
extrêmement violente ça suppose d'avoir
un rapport de violence intellectuelle en
tout cas par rapport à soi-même et de ne
jamais s'asseoir de ne jamais se compler
quand on débat avec quelqu'un quand on
discute avec quelqu'un est-ce que le but
est d'avoir raison d'écraser mon
adversaire de le torpiller de me dire
voilà je l'ai éclaté et je lui montrer
qu'il avait complètement tort sur le
modèle presque du combat de boxe ou
est-ce que le but est d'essayer de se
rapprocher ensemble à deux de quelque
chose qui s'apparenterait entre
guillemets sinon la vérité du moins à
une pensée qui soit la plus construite
la plus complexe la plus fiable la plus
à l'image de ce qu'on essaye de penser
et ça ça suppose à un moment au milieu
du débat un moment de sa vie de pouvoir
dire bah écoutez non j'ai tort je tu as
raison ton argument gagne j'observe
personnellement que je vois rarement
cela sur les réseaux sociaux que il y a
des exceptions mais que j'ai
l'impression que c'est pas tellement ce
qui est valorisé dans les espaces de
discussion notamment au sens politique
du terme qu'on observe sur les réseaux
les réseaux sociaux et plus largement la
révolution production numérique peut
avoir comme effet on reviendra peut-être
sur les effets positifs de cette
révolution numérique mais peut avoir
comme effet extrêmement dangereux de
mettre en péril le la démarche de penser
contre soi-même avec ce fameux effet
notamment de ce qu'on appelle la bulle
de filtre ça veut dire quand je vais sur
Twitter quand je vais sur facebook quand
je vais sur Instagram le fil d'actualité
qu'on va montrer est un fil d'actualité
qui est personnalisé alors naturellement
en fonction des pages que je suis et
souvent les pages que je suis par
exemple pour les pages d'actualité
correspondent à des médias dont j'ai
envie de voir le contenu donc des médias
avec lesquels disons je suis plutôt
d'accord correspond avec les pages de ce
que vont écrire mes amis et c'est vrai
que je peux avoir tendance à avoir des
amis qui vont avoir des affinités
intellectuelles idéologiques culturelles
avec moi et puis aussi l'algorithme ça
dépend des réseaux mais l'algorithme
peut repérer les contenus sur lesquels
je vais passer de plus en plus de temps
les contenus qui m'intéressent plus ou
moins etc ce qui fait que à la fin des
fins quand j'ouvre mon fil d'actualité
pour par exemple pour savoir ce qui
s'est passé dans les 24 dernières heures
sur Twitter je ne vais voir du réel que
ce que je veux en voir à partir un
moment où je vais avoir comme rapport
aux réseaux sociaux de me dire que ce
que j'attends de ce n'est pas qu'il
m'informe au risque d'ailleurs d'aller
contre mes idées de me faire un peu de
métaux et de me choquer etc mais ce que
je veux c'est qu'ils viennent confirmer
ce que j'attends déjà de voir qu'ils
viennent confirmer la pré idée que je me
fais du réel et de ce qui se passe dans
le monde là où c'est dangereux c'est que
nous assistons à un morcellement du réel
est-ce qu'il y a pas une difficulté
supplémentaire aujourd'hui sur la mise
en avant des valeurs de l'engagement
c'est à dire que c'est difficile de
penser contre soi à partir du moment où
on dit qu'il y a des valeurs en fait
objectives et que du coup si on conteste
ces valeurs là si on pense qu'on soit
même ça veut dire qu'en fait on a plus
de valeur
oui c'est cette phrase qu'on entend
souvent des gens qui disent j'ai mes
valeurs et en disant ça ils disent le
contraire de ce qu'ils veulent dire
parce que quand on dit j'ai mes valeurs
ça supposerait qu'il y ait des choses
des idées des principes ce qu'on entend
par là des idées des principes qui
seraient transcendant qui serait au
dessus de moi et qui serait
effectivement comme ça qui pourrait
régir toute mon existence et en même
temps quand on dit parce qu'il serait
absolu et en même temps quand on dit
j'ai mes valeurs évidemment c'est la
grande question Nietzsche quelle est la
valeur de mes valeurs et évidemment que
la valeur c'est toujours quelque chose à
quoi moi j'ai donné de la valeur ou nous
collectivement une époque une société en
milieu sociale nous avons donné de la
valeur à ceci ou cela si je tiens le
beau pour une valeur si je tiens le vrai
pour une valeur si je tiens d'ailleurs
l'amour pour une valeur tout ça ne sont
absolument pas des principes absolus
mais ce sont des choses dans lesquelles
moi j'ai décidé d'accord enfin auquel
moi j'ai décidé d'accorder de prêter
précisément une valeur au sens la
presque marchand du terrain et donc en
effet cette notion de valeur me
semble-t-il et absolument
compatible avec la pensée avec le
travail de la pensée le travail de la
pensée moi je le définirais comme
précisément une pensée qui ne se soucie
pas des valeurs et qui ne se soucie pas
ni des valeurs ni d'ailleurs des visions
du monde qui essayent d'avancer alors ça
veut pas dire d'être danger de posture
adolescente de dire je vais briser
toutes les idoles moi j'ai aucune valeur
dire que on a aucune valeur c'est déjà
aussi affirmé une valeur une valeur
inversée mais c'est aussi une valeur
mais en revanche penser sans se soucier
de la valeur et des valeurs qu'on
aimerait avoir parce qu'évidemment que
les valeurs elles orientent la pensée
elles orientent la réflexion donc je
pense qu'il faut absolument se méfier
des valeurs et que les gens qui disent
qu'il faut défendre les valeurs ne
comprennent même pas ce qu'ils disent et
qu'en fait dire ça c'est presque
l'inverse de ce qu'on de ce qu'on croit
à dire